[Music]
follow the light how do you feel Daniels
alright any dizziness nausea hmm fine so
however viewing it it is pure majesty
I don't know what you're talking about
kind of spooks me out some big old
seeing nothing closely will commence in
153 minutes a lot one hour before taking
the purgative and please ensure to
consume the requisite liquid and vitamin
back I just wanted to say hey before I
get out I'm feeling kind of crazy well
you know feeling good I'm spurning up I
thought we're gonna have one more drink
before he went into cryo sleep
who's gonna lead us at our toasts said
to him do something she know what to say
all right captain make sure your own
vase oh yeah you kill me all right
hey captain like never happens feel
better
is he gone yep let's party
I got 2,500 handsome young buck right
here all right
I still love you Halas Xbox one merging
up some long uncomfortable feel oh
please not charge wide open - I will
slide this Junction eyes all over this
table right tenancy can be a jerk why
you speak so loudly I know he can't hear
me his drama Danny's will be strong his
wife is in the drunker you see now I
heard about these crazy bugs just
outside the colonial pumps apparently
they look like cockroaches besides a
giant little oops okay first of all stop
who I'm trying to eat oh come on this is
barely food but I love is the last time
to have this meatloaf
my name is grandma's apple pie yeah how
their mom is barbecue nachos but I made
last exam judicial notice yes it's the
best meet your anything on the fruits on
that man okay down the wrong pipe
I've got your back oh that was a joke
right thank you
so what about that speech Daniels mmm I
have a bomb prepared sorry yeah Jake
asked me to say something that's okay
please you've all sacrificed so much to
be here
to be a part of this it's the first-ever
large-scale colonization mission to
compass barn to our galaxy making
history
everyone back on earth is really
grateful or your hard work your courage
I just want to say I couldn't pick a
better bunch of jerks to get marooned on
a distant planet with so to the
continent Jaroussky eyes open